c'est un drame qui a bouleversé le monde
entier hier l'accident d'hélicoptère
survenu dimanche dans la matinée au nord
ouest de los angeles causant la mort de
neuf individus dont le champion de
basket kobe bryant et sa fille gina âgée
de 13 ans kobe bryant les décédé ce
dimanche dans le crash de son
hélicoptère kobe bryant est décédée cet
immense star du basket qui est décédé un
accident terrible qui s'est déroulé à
calabasas en californie 7 à 9h47 que les
autorités locales ont reçu un appel
d'urgence signalant un accident de ce
quartier riche de los angeles
un accident qui serait survenu quelques
minutes plus tôt provoquant au moment de
l'arrivée des secours des feux de
broussailles
kobe bryant était en route avec le coach
d'un établissement scolaire de los
angeles pour se rendre à un des
entraînements de sa fille gina marché
depuis plusieurs années sur les traces
de son père un accident qui serait en
partie de la faute du pilote qui aurait
décidé de faire décoller l'appareil
alors que les conditions météorologiques
n'étaient pas réunies les obligeant à
volait trop bas ce qui serait la cause
de l'impact avec le sol
selon les autorités sur place la
situation météorologique ne répondait
pas à nos normes minimales de vol des
autorités qui n'aurait elle même pas eu
la possibilité de faire décoller leur
propre hélicoptère quelques instants
après ce drame l'america prenait
désarmer la disparition de cette star
âgée de seulement 41 ans
voilà alors il ya eu énormément dommage
a commis moyens de bien entendu on en a
vu partout et c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont été choqué par
le traitement médiatique aussi de cette
info puisque je vous le dis comme aux
états unis les chaînes d'info françaises
ont diffusé les images de la carcasse
encore fumante de l'hélico regarde le
drame s'est produit aux alentours de 10
heures dans ce relief escarpé de la
petite ville de kalaba ça au nord de los
angeles kobe bryant voyager dans son
hélicoptère privé en compagnie de
plusieurs personnes dont diana une de
ses filles
il n'y a aucun survivant toujours selon
les médias sur place
beaucoup de réactions de stupéfaction
sur les réseaux sociaux les
circonstances du drame commence à
s'éclaircir kobe bryant sa fille ana
maria 13 ans et sept autres personnes
étaient à bord quand l'appareil a pris
feu
la raison du crash n'est pas encore
connu mais la météo n'étaient pas bonnes
y avait beaucoup de brouillard et c'est
peut-être un début d'explication
voilà alors c'est vrai que il ya plein
de gens sur les réseaux sociaux qui ont
envie qu'il fallait pas diffuser nous on
les a diffusés voilà les images de crash
bandicoot souvent pensé gym a beaucoup
de choses me gêne depuis le départ
d'abord le site américain qui sort ça
avant les autorités ils ont l'habitude
nom était exactement donc la famille
n'étaient pas prévenues et ensuite on
dis ces enfants tous ces enfants étaient
dans l'hélicoptère puis aucun enfant une
fille je trouve ça un manque de maîtrise
globale et moi je pense qu'on aurait dû
prendre du recul même si c'est une star
internationale que le choc est
planétaire
sauf que les médias américains et
français ont trop tôt diffuser ces
images de carcasses fumantes
enfin je trouve que c'était presque
indécent il aurait fallu à mon avis
prendre davantage de recul mais dont je
rêve ou des départs de nous alors je
suis pas d'alcool mais non plus la
german wings vous souvenez de cet avion
ce qui compliquera brouillé on était
tout de suite ah non c'est un fait
d'actualité
tu as fait d'actualité ou alors à ce que
que je conçois qu'on aille parfois trop
vite dans la diffusion d'informations
qu'on se trompe d'accord mais sinon les
images on peut pas opérer comment on ne
montre on montre plus rien alors je sais
pas je sais pas enfin je sais le
traitement se disait torino dont on
parle pas de jean kandé moi ça m'énerve
comme valérie l'une d'elles aux phoques
sur l'autoroute quand les gens regardent
l'odeur du ski c'est chiant ça c'est
vraiment ça m'énerve mais là on parle de
légende on parle pas de de quelqu'un de
lambda on parle de légende et
souvenez-vous ça toujours on a toujours
eu des photos de 2,2 de carcassonne
quand albert camus james dissolue je sus
balavoine tous ces gens-là ayrton senna
on a tout le temps eu lui c'était sur
circuit on a tout le temps eu les images
parce que les gens ont besoin de ça les
gens qui avaient le poster de kobe
bryant avec qu'ils ont grandi qui les a
aidés à traverser les épreuves ils sont
réveillés avec le matin ils sont touchés
avec 8 soit ils ont besoin de visualiser
que c'est vraiment fini c'est fini c'est
pas une section michel serres on a
toujours vu mais à mesa quand même ça
éveille quelque part ça ça suscite le
goût du sang qu'ont les gens quand même
parce que les images n'apporterait
l'explication du crash
quand on voit les une explication voix
l'agglo à montagnac au texte à la
l'image ne donne rien et tu fais que de
la fumée
yahia je vous dis il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont dérangé aussi là dessus
une séquence qui n'a pas plu du tout
téléspectateur et je vous dis c'est sur
bfm tv c'est lorsqu'un journaliste a
évoqué le scandale sexuel qui a entaché
la réputation de playboy avait en 2003
alors que l'hélicoptère venait à peine
de s'écraser
aussi l'on verrait rien à voir voilà
droit si je peux le détaillant avait 41
ans il est considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs joueurs de nba tous les temps
pour les passionnés de basket c'est bien
simple c'est le nouveau michael jordan
la seule ombre à son portrait c'est
lorsqu'il a eu une relation extra
conjugale avec une employée d'un hôtel
en 2003 et l'accusé de viol ce avait eu
un énorme retentissement ici ils avaient
perdu des sponsors mais il restera une
légende du basket
attends je voudrais quand même précisé
qu'il avait perdu espoir sur ce qui me
gêne dans le le le commentaire de mon
collègue de mon collègue ce qui me gêne
c'est que il dit simplement il avait été
accusé de deux heures mais il dit pas la
fin mais de ce qui s'est passé dit pas
que elle n'a jamais témoigné contre lui
woods renonce le préciser est blanchi
dans cette affaire alors qu'ils
nourrissent ils avaient évoqué s'il veut
évoquer ce fait-là de la vie de kobe
bryant
qu'il aille au bout et ça c'est sûr
c'est la surface a énormément déranger
et c'est que c'était mal d'élus dont
parlait place est maintenant plus qu il
était juré c'est parce qu'on veut pas en
parler trop vite donc il n'a pas le
temps de fignoler son papier et serrait
info is where non mais là ce que disait
on annonce un bilan de milan voilà
exactement c'est pas tellement les
images le problème c'est plutôt la
corrida l'info là c'est savoir villa pas
dire un truc comme ça il est 22h 5 on
apprend à 20h45 5 c'est pas les mêmes
lui ça doit pas sentir ni à gauche ni à
innover réussi par allah il apparaît
fléché dans cette suite les deux pôles
hélico si je vous le dis c'est que
quelques heures à peine après l annonce
de la mort de communes rien des sites se
sont mis à commercialiser des produits
dérivés à l'effigié du joueur
on trouve par exemple des tee-shirts rip
kobe à 19,83 c'est incroyable des sweats
reste une piste kobe comme et des
stickers il connaît et ça ça aussi les
gens ont dit que c'était inadmissible
gérer puni entrait franchement pas ce
que c'est c'est jamais foulé aux pieds
sa mémoire
on voit plein de concours lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux gagner un maillot là nos
francs là on est dans l'indécence pour
moi voilà l'impression que le business
est obscène de la mort a toujours existé
d'inscrites et de tomber comme ça alors
et en plus moi au niveau 2 du traitement
de l'information on est dans une société
de delà de l'information à outrance de
la transparence
on veut tout savoir et si ça sort pas
sur les médias dire bsl cnn
traditionnels ce sera sur les réseaux
sociaux
aujourd'hui c'est sur les réseaux
sociaux sur alors en fait ces aventures
oui mais ça passe et même d'avant et ça
concerne le 6 mai les anonymes que les
gens connus pardonnez moi mon frère un
accident d'avion en 91 et la femme de
mon patron à vsd me dit t'as pas un
frère qui s'appelle emmanuel bove jeudi
oui mais le menu et je crois bien qu'il
est mort et ce n'était pas le cas il
était la vue des mois et des mois
d'hôpital mais donc ça arrive à tout le
monde c'est inévitable et il y avait des
photos partout de l'hélicoptère ensemble
aussi on peut pas éviter ça alors il ya
un truc incroyable s'est passé mais un
dessin animé avait prédit le crash de
kobe bryant
c'était dans un épisode diffusé en 2017
regarder le dessin animé s'appelle
legends of chamberland eyes bon mon
anglais n'est pas au fond
on voulait montrer ça c'est incroyable
c'était le 28 décembre 2017
voilà dans un dessin animé voilà
résolument vous montrer ce à voyager
beaucoup un hélicoptère ainsi qu'aux
c'est sûr à ce perso dire qu'il avait
louée
alors je vous le dis interrogé par les
médias d'un pilote américain qui vit
près du lieu de l'accident qui a mis en
cause le manque de visibilité au moment
du crash
mais on ne dit pas non à kobe bryant
arriver dit je veux emmener à taylor
dent je veux le pilote baida pas dit non
même si les conditions étaient mauvaises
c'est ça à dire c'est ça le truc aussi
comme jean-michel son pilote il est viré
autres aussi dit non
si l'objet de deux bassins secteur de
bagnols et ses pilotes des dirigeants
étaient alertés par les lacs lui contre
les aliments frits vrai c'était un
énorme mental restera bien entendu bien
et on pense très fort à sa famille